en chine n'y a personne dans les rues de
cannes aujourd'hui encore eu en revanche
vacance totale est flagrante du pouvoir
qui ne donne pratiquement plus signe de
vie après quatre jours hui ne s'est pas
passé grand chose d'ailleurs on a
l'impression ce soir que la victoire
étudiante est imminente il va falloir
qu'elle se concrétise par quelque chose
et ce quelque chose ce pourrait bien
être la démission du premier ministre
chinois li peng francine raymond
crime de lèse majesté le portrait géant
de mao tsé toung qui trône à l'entrée de
la cité interdite éclaboussée de
peinture les étudiants de la place
tiananmen qui n'ont jamais contesté
l'héritage du grand timonier faire la
provocation ils remettront eux mêmes les
trois coupables à la police depuis
quatre jours la loi martiale it in a
piqué la vacance du pouvoir est totale
les étudiants chinois aurait-il gagné
ils étaient un million cet après midi à
manifester pour exiger le limogeage du
premier ministre li peng limogeage
implicitement confirmé ce soir par l'
agence chine nouvelle qui remarque
depuis que le premier ministre a déclaré
la loi martiale le peuple est descendu
tous les jours dans la rue l' agence
chinoise oublie de mentionner que les
étudiants réclament aussi la démission
de dan zhang ping le numéro un chinois
ne s'est pas montré en public depuis sa
poignée de main historique avec mikhaïl
gorbatchev il ya une semaine
l'ipag vous l'êtes employer la manière
forte contre les étudiants qui réclament
et plus et démocratie lui aussi disparu
on s'attend au retour du patron du parti
communiste et aux ions mise en minorité
vendredi depuis le début il était
partisan du dialogue
seuls des changements de têtes sommet
permettra dans un premier temps de
désamorcer la crise nous avons le
sentiment d'avoir été profondément
humilié a dit ce matin un colonel de
l'armée nous n'avons rencontré que des
gens raisonnables faisant preuve d'une
grande sagesse les étudiants de
tiananmen ont soulevé des problèmes de
fond il faudra les résoudre